he's like oh so have you joined the
closing or black program because you
know this guy is basically like yeah I
want to hire you
he basically structured in such a way
whereas if you join the inner circle
you're gonna get a higher points of my
life is YouTube videos are not even
comparable to how shitty is like stuff
is you know you should have a sexual
relationship with mine what hey guys
welcome to faith guru today we have
another special edition we're having
another interview with a former high
ticket closer course person who's gonna
give his testimonial his name is Joel
thanks for coming on the show yeah no
bro tell us a little bit about how you
how you got into the the thing tell us
when you were in high ticket closure
yeah so um I recently got a job in sales
that was doing really well man I think I
made like $8,000 my first month and that
was really good for me I was like [ __ ]
man I can okay grew up on welfare and
food stamps you can be a grand you're
like damn what the hell is going on and
and then the next month though it
crashed really bad I only did like 4,000
what were you selling cars water
softeners okay okay yeah yeah and yeah
and I was like oh [ __ ] what's going on
man so I figured okay something
something's happening right because it
was my first time in cells I didn't have
any sales experience so I started going
on YouTube looking up okay I had to get
good at sells and whatnot
that's what I found people like Grant
Cardone I found Dan Locke and so I
started watching his videos you know the
whole what was it the whole oh the
Bentley or the on night thing you know
yeah do you want to be the most extreme
want to be Bentley in your industry or
you want to be the Hyundai correct and I
am the [ __ ] belly and of course not
no like it really I was I'm just I'm
good at sales for some reason you don't
talking about yeah it's like you can
have a kid it's good at art but he
doesn't know why he's good he's just
good at it I just happened to get it
sells so I didn't know that that was you
know [ __ ] I was like okay I mean I I
[ __ ] gas and selected
right and so I started watching these
videos for a couple months and whatnot
and then I guess he released something
called damn Japan which is like a
monthly subscription sir what is it like
to say that again Dan on demand yeah
it's like a monthly subscription service
it's like 50 bucks or whatever and I was
like and at the time right this is
before I knew anything about marketing
or anything like that and it you know
it's a quick funnel page which by the
way I don't know how the hell anyone
using click funnels makes money that
looks so skinny
I really don't so scamming I [ __ ] dude I
mean clickfunnels like the web pages I'm
like [ __ ] is it gonna go to some bank
account like you know in China or
something no no anyhow I was like I
didn't I didn't buy it
hell no this looks this looks hella
sketchy and then you know I you know
YouTube and Facebook is like okay well
you know they keep spinning me a bunch
of gurus like hey learn how to double
yourselves you don't talk in my facebook
oh yeah and so I started clicking on all
of them
just to see and it was you know the same
click fun and stuff so I'm like okay
well maybe it's just an industry
standard thing I don't know about right
you know maybe maybe people you know
selling informational programs don't
know you know how to make their stuff
not look spammy so I decided to go for
the Dandong demand thing I pay the 50
bucks for the month to see what it was
like um yeah it was a massive
disappointment just it was like the
biggest disappointments of my life I
think I need to get a reef oh my gosh it
was basically him uploading all of his
YouTube videos and then a few like it
was like four live calls he made if they
were alive they'd bring him in live if
him just talking about copyrighting and
money and you know oh you should have a
sexual relationship with month just
[ __ ] beard right
wow what a sexual relationship with
money yeah yeah yeah so on I can't
exactly but it's something like you need
to think of money like a lover imagine
if you tell your lover I hate you for I
don't need you that lovers with you to
trick money like your lover just like
I'm not for real he's for real
I'm sorry what he's for real about that
he means that well I don't know I mean
he said in the live calls I assume he's
Ferrell who knows but he really likes
money I could tell you that much
and yeah I remember one of these things
was uh it was like the high ticket
closure program he was advertising MMH
of role plays with his people and
whatnot and I thought oh okay this
actually seems pretty legit let me look
into it and then uh you know I looked
into it and it was like 2,500 bucks I'm
like oh that seems a little bit high
because you know is I don't have a point
of reference you know what I mean like
I've never bought any kind of
informational products in my life right
so I had no you don't say you don't have
a point of reference if you don't know
you didn't know right that's other time
sure people get you and I just I decided
to go for it eventually I was like okay
yeah sure I'll look into it I was a
little bit nervous because I'm like no
Dan on demand was such a [ __ ] product I
don't know how you thought it was gonna
get better yeah you know what the thing
is I just didn't know I didn't know
there were other programs out there it
was like I think it was like before
grant cardone started really advertising
and doubling down and whatnot right I
went for it
and it was like II said oh it's gonna be
live training and whatnot and I thought
oh okay cool
so I went through it and the first two
because it's once a week right it's like
it's a seven week for the HTC is a
seven-week program and once a week you
get a four-hour life call with Dan that
he teaches all of his HTC people at the
same time and it's actually you can
actually use discord crazy enough which
blew my [ __ ] mind I'm like what
discord supposed to be a professional
Society you want to go on the site
that's literally just animate video
games in form like okay yeah sure I
guess whatever and
I know right if crate I was like where
we discord okay yeah I mean I was
thinking maybe slack now you know okay
this course sure and we basically just
mindset training for the first two weeks
I don't even remember what it was just
bunch of horseshit
oh you know like stuff you find in a
Tony Robbins book except you know four
hours of it and then you started getting
into the actual sales training oh I want
to mention something just for people who
don't know you know when you think of
Dan lock have you seen his YouTube
videos you think of this really high
produced thing something with like
beautiful graphics and like this
beautifully that is not the case with
the HTC tell people what you get for
your twenty five hundred bucks you get
you can I'm not making this up you get
there's a there's an app or something
it's called zoom is that what it is yeah
yeah yeah it's like a Skype clone
whatever the hell and it's a [ __ ]
it's not even like hyper Duchenne it's
him literally just saying hey people HTC
here yeah and it's just it's an image of
just dance face it's just an image of
Dan's face right there like that
pictures just pictures right I was
expecting you know okay maybe you know
they're gonna be live like a podcast no
it's basic you can literally not even
look at the screen and know what's going
on it is literally just that it's just
it's basically a podcast except you
don't even get the visuals right even
lower than Jill Rogan and you pay 2500
for it oh my goodness yeah and that's it
and I was but I was like okay cuz you
know but again I've never done anything
self alright no self point of reference
right like I didn't have any I did not
have a point of reference I didn't know
the mindset stuff he gave me even though
it was extremely basic I just I didn't
know so I went with it you know and
throughout the entire like from day one
he's like there's no refunds
you don't get refunds here you don't get
refunds here he says that he actually
says that yeah day one you don't get
refunds no refunds I don't do refunds I
was like okay whatever right but I'm
finally getting a refund and then week
three comes along
he starts teaching actual sales stuff
and he teaches this really shitty method
it's called personality based sells okay
are you familiar with it all I know is
that he asks way too many questions he
turns everything into a stupid question
I'll get him in just a second so okay
okay so he teaches you there's like four
main personality types right there's
emeralds rubies sapphires and pearls
pearls are you know really quiet people
like to bond with you it's that
personality type staff arch like you
know what oak and Paul or you know Jake
Paul a kind of personality emeralds
would be much like an engineer or
something like that and rubies would be
like a you know a cutthroat businessman
like mr. full on Shark Tank or whatever
and he's like how you close these people
and he talks like okay you know Emeril
they like to just see numbers and that's
it nothing else don't even worry about
that [ __ ] and then and then it gets it's
just a bunch of [ __ ] questions so so
a damn walk okay so the other stuff
right everything else is dealing with
objections and all that but that's like
the main focus of the program so good
let's talk about the Dan Locke questions
so he's like okay okay okay so typically
in a real sell scenario there's the
initial greeting
yeah there's qualifying questions
there's the pitch and then there's the
clothes and then objection handling at
the end right oh yeah you know what I
mean absolutely clothes I did the sound
toast that's exactly what you do yeah
that's what you do that's what you
there's nothing else anything else is
[ __ ] but again a guy who's a
natural-born salesman it doesn't
actually know what Y is good didn't know
that oh all he does is he's like okay
she's asked a bunch of questions like
ask about the family ask about you know
their what they like to for fun ask uh
you know how well how it would affect
their kids if they bought the product or
whatever it was he's like just just ask
a billion questions and whatnot just
just keep asking question
and asking questions of whatnot he does
not teach you how to pitch a product
does not teach you how to pitch anything
there's like we don't do sales be closed
and and that is the that is the kind of
stuff that you can believe if you've
never done sales before but the second
you do sales you understand what kind of
garbage that is look and and for the
people who don't know like what I'm
talking about
you can go watch my video about Dan
Locke's like fake sales calls but uh
like literally the way he handles like
basic things and it's so clear that he's
not he's not a sales guy someone will be
like hey Dan like look I'm just worried
about the cost can we bring the cost
down and he'll be like well let me ask
you why are you worried about the cost
well and the person would be like well
dude it's just a lot of money because
why is it a lot of money well dude I
mean it's just a lot of money for me
like can you just please like we lower
the price here well how would you feel
it and it's just he never gets to an
answer I can't imagine how frustrating
as a customer that would be to never
hear a straight answer to anything and
always be like having it reversed it's
like playing the reverse card anew no
it's like reverse exactly oh yeah oh
yeah and that's what he teaches right so
like I think it's week five or six I'm
not quite sure and he's like we're gonna
teach you how to handle objections and
then okay and I'm not joking right so
it's like okay how he did it was this he
he puts an objection on the screen like
I need to think about it and then we're
gonna stay oh like everybody say that in
discord go ooh
everybody just go oh it's an objection
he's like now what you want to do you
want to be like watch out and he's like
cuz he like he loves Bruce Lee by the
way he loves Bruce if Bruce Lee was a
girl he'd be all up in that like no joke
so basically he's like like in G condo
they teach you the finger jab you jab
them in this in the eye and that's how
you went every fight I was like I was
like okay that seems kind of [ __ ]
I'm pretty sure Conor McGregor would
knock your [ __ ] ass
out of you tried that but okay whatever
you know a lot of martial arts [ __ ]
anyhow so he's like so if anyone ever
give you an objection your finger jab
you redirect that's what you do so it's
like I need to think about it okay cool
you know I I learned the Jordan Bill for
it straight line system so I don't even
know how to like and alanjaques really
now but it over like oh I think you're a
bit too young
okay how old would you like someone to
be just stupid stuff like yeah is that
when you start realizing that this is a
bunch of garbage I realized was a bunch
of [ __ ] when I started applying it
to my real job but I couldn't close
anything it does not work in real life
it only works under a very specific
occasion they already want to buy the
product and they're calling you because
they just have some concerns like oh can
you come off the price a little bit or
what exactly is in the program because
you know the shitty little thing that
took me here is really you know sketchy
and work on I want to talk to somebody
tell me about tell me about the hire
thing that they promised you a job or
whatever so this okay so let's talk
about the hiring part right do you know
how they said okay well if you put in a
lot of hours we'll hire you and why not
right okay so basically there's like in
eighth class he's like oh good
attendance will get a special class it's
just him piping everybody up but uh you
know he cuz again and you have an
emotional connection with this dude
you've been with this guy role playing
for like seven weeks straight right no
but you know it's it's like I called
almost you know it's almost like you've
been great last foursome in weeks or
eight at this point and you know he's
like okay I want you guys to join my
inner circle if you can't afford it you
need to buy it was like $2,100 to join
the inner circle when he says if you
can't afford it you need to buy it it's
exactly why you need to buy it because
you can't afford it and you know alright
okay right because typically you'd be
like oh what [ __ ] idiot would fall
for that right but again if you if
you've already established in
emotional connection with someone it's a
lot it's a lot easier to seep in right
it's like the Colts like here just wear
these clothes it's fine whatever
you know what's that I was it the
foot-in-the-door phenomenon you asked
for a little bit every single time and
eventually it works up like that he
pretty much changed people into joy is
inner circle program right by $2,100 and
then two hundred dollars a month on top
of that every single time the stand is
inner circle and I was like well you
know what I'm devoted in this I'm gonna
go for it and so I bought it twenty one
hundred blocks came out of my pocket
stupid dumb no I'm a [ __ ] decision
and well you know it's great cuz now you
could tell everybody at home all about
it we can hear all about it
go on YouTube so yeah they're definitely
gonna hear about this part basic okay
okay and so it basically gives you
access so I think there's like a web
service or something we're like all
these people they you can go online to
their courses and whatnot they'll use
the same video format anyhow it takes
you to another like website it has the
inner circle stuff there's like a whole
bunch of videos like you know goal
setting just but I didn't know
unfortunately so I'm like this is really
I was like man like we're talking lower
quality than an htc program this inner
circle is like look it's like way more
[ __ ] expensive okay this is something
people don't understand how this works
how the quality actually gets worse
what like Dan Locke's incentive is to
make all the free stuff actually the
nicest stuff because he's trying to sell
you on the fact that he's gonna give you
great stuff and he keeps promising
either or promising me the world but
when you've actually paid all of a
sudden he has no incentive to make that
course better
I mean yep except for testimonials like
this no no yeah that's a good point his
YouTube videos are not even comparable
to how shitty his like stuff is like not
even comparable like
has Oh like he's old and YouTube videos
if you go back and look at his old days
it's just him you know giving a speech
or whatever like what do they call like
master class masterminds yeah yeah
whatever the hell it is it's just him
talking and one on the quality's like
you know 480p and whatnot
man it's even worse than yeah dude it's
awful oh yeah and holistic okay yeah get
on with the story is right so I'm like
and this is really shitty [ __ ]
quality but you know he you know and oh
and during the 8th class he literally
says ya know we're gonna hire you
we're gonna do this kind of stuff he's
basically like selling us a job
it's basically woody so he's essentially
like hinting to you oh we're gonna have
you are we hire our high ticket closers
that kind of thing yeah we hire people
from my inner circle so no and I mean it
took me a while to figure it out but he
basically structured in such a way
whereas if you join the inner circle
you're gonna get hired so everyone
thinks to themselves oh I like this guy
like I would love working with this guy
exactly exactly
ok so anyhow um my group leader contacts
me on Facebook right he's like hey Oh
cuz we have weekly we have like groups
and whatnot and he contacts me says
eight so much from the inner circle
wants to get in contact with you Joel
and I was like oh this is awesome man
you know like this is really really cool
I'm gonna get hired this is freaking
awesome
you know cuz I join the oh you're really
good here I'll make more money and then
do contact me he's like yeah yeah let's
do an hour you know call role play and
he just basically interviews me for an
hour we don't actually get to role play
he's like oh you know let's let's let's
let's schedule another appointment and
do it again all right but ya know I'm
really just based on the way you talk to
me I think I want you on my sales team
Wow I was like okay cool and then this
is what this is this this this part
right here this is what tipped me over
the edge cuz you know this guy is
basically like yeah I want to hire you
what not he's you know he's officially
associated with a mark
just some dude he's like officially
they're like in hotter ranks so he's
like oh so have you joined the closer
and black program which is like I talked
about MLM stuff so no there's like a
giant conference in Vancouver or
whatever the Dan lock as is called
closers in black and he'll wear black
suits
oh no this Col this closer thing is so
cringy dude like the height to get
closer it's so bad it's so bad and so
right if you guys like oh I'll be
joining you know I'm like oh I don't
think I'm gonna go he's like yeah you
need to come but this dude's about to
hire me right on my [ __ ] looks really
bad if I don't go you know what I mean
like Mikey might decide against him
right huh no no I totally understand
you're thinking he might not think I'm
devoted enough i right and he basically
shamed me into doing this thing and
guess how much it cost to just go to
this [ __ ] dinner just take a wild
guess I don't know like $200 yeah about
250 bucks and I was like I don't want to
[ __ ] pay that but he'll you know what
if I sunk four grand in at this point
you know I'm like will [ __ ] if this guy
does give me a job and I start making
money it's not gonna matter right it's
not gonna matter and then until he's
like oh yeah by the way we have a VIP
upgrade if you want [ __ ] can you upsell
this different [ __ ] upsells me and
then uh it's like an extra hundred
dollars and I'm like dude I don't want
to [ __ ] go and I'm like oh yeah okay
fine just just do it let's get it over
with
that's okay fine whatever he's like okay
cool and this was around December time
that this happened he's like all right
so I think I'm gonna be starting a sales
team sometime in January I'll let you
know then I was like okay cool January
comes around he's like yeah I decided
against it I'm not gonna hire you on and
I was I was like I was [ __ ] I was
[ __ ] pissed like I was livid I'm like
he's like we can still roleplay though
if he wants because I'm a promise you
that I'm like
this time like I was so [ __ ] mad I
then I said I sent supporting email
because he has HTC support I said I want
a refund now for the inner clock for the
inner circle program it's like that you
know that's that's that that's [ __ ] not
to basically you know to have Dan Locke
say oh yeah we're gonna hire you and
someone contacts you and then sells you
more [ __ ] and it doesn't hire you I was
like that's that's [ __ ] off
yes okay that's terrible dad that I was
like that's bad like that is really
messed up and then I watch in a couple
days they never got back to me oh by the
way I'll get into how they don't respond
to reflux very well of course they don't
of course they don't and I was like no
you know what so I contacted chase I
said look I got scammed I'm a refund on
the inter closer program right now like
I just needed the chart and no jump that
day like because they said okay it's
gonna take you know five to seven
business days to get through or whatever
after about five days I got an email
from HTC Sephora my [ __ ] man it's
like hey can you not just get to charge
we'll just give you the refund and I was
like oh okay sure because it's all night
you know recurring payment whatever they
say we need to you need it I want to
speak the charts we can cancel that
recurring payment and I was like okay
fine
so I you know undid charge told him
about it maybe give me my money back but
it took me having to call my [ __ ]
bank for an hour disputing the damn
charge and it was just oh god it's so
[ __ ] don't like [ __ ] me they make it
like pulling teeth to get a refund oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah it was a
few things I learn to talk about what I
say group leaders and group leaders MLM
and the seafood I actually have heard
about the seafood thing from I talked to
this other guy calling and and I just
heard about in general it's like so
weird that he makes people call him
seafood what the hell is up with that
let me go with the seafood thing okay so
you know how
what's it called a priest you call them
father yeah like you know it's like it's
like a title of respect right right
right right of course your grace for a
king or whatever yeah an honorific right
right and like a key
I guess see flute means like teacher for
life in Chinese or something I I guess I
don't remember I know it means teach or
something
and Jeff sorry so when I jump Chinese
because he's mad or whatever and ya know
like he's like listen if you call me
Sifu meanings it means what we bonded
forever and it basically like a lot of
its people was owning him as seafood si
si fu and yeah and he just is everybody
just starts calling him Sifu and he does
it in such a way but he either responds
to himself as seafood when he's teaching
you by the way he's like yes
you want to make Sifu happy don't you
you know just holding big happy and
roleplay and yeah it's really cringey I
was like that seems kinda weird and I
started thinking about on like [ __ ]
that's like a [ __ ] hole that's like a
mind game that's like a next-level mind
game like I'm your teacher for life you
have to listen to me right it's like
it's like if you're you know it's like
you know I had to say the abuse is in
the Catholic Church like father why am I
taking my pants off it's like don't
worry child it's more got purpose order
you know except in this case you know
yeah mom takes your money office there
so it's sort of like that it's sort of
like you know there's some thing and
whatnot I never called him Sifu I'm like
I never really liked the son of a [ __ ]
to begin with but I was like well hell
if he can help me make more money I
don't care that's how they didn't happen
oh you know I was gonna mention this you
know how you talked about on one of your
fake gurus video there was a guy named
cave on he's in the htc program I'm not
sure if you're aware of that I can't say
I can't say anything about it I cannot
say anything about it I can say [ __ ]
about that
this [ __ ] Caden I did not know that he
had a fake Harvard thing and dad Lak
that ok whoa let me say something real
quick I didn't know either
I did I was shocked to find Kavon on
that fake Harvard thing and I had to put
him in and I was like I'm not I'm not
playing favorites with anybody
great yeah and in Haley he was he was
really associated with Dan walk a lot
right like I mean like he was he was
like he was sucking his [ __ ]
like just right up a sport and this dude
[ __ ] ji-yong you know okay and then
apparently about halfway through I was
in season seven he breaks everything in
two seasons right and seven comes around
rhyme at I think was like four or five
he's like he posts because there's like
a Facebook group you know the HTC
Facebook family group
yeah because T C family Facebook group
by the way yeah cuz it's a family right
family that you know takes your money
class and you know he had he basically
says you know warning warden we have an
announcement there's a serious problem
whose betrayal in the family and whatnot
I guess and it's like you know Facebook
you can you can pin it at the top gather
around seafood to find out what the
problem in the family is series problem
a serious update I guess
the cave on dude like was recruiting HTC
students or something like that
and he made this big [ __ ] deal like
he is excommunicated from our family no
one will make contact with him at all
like basically like disowning them from
the family yeah oh by the way just for
everybody watching that cave undo was a
search day with HTC for like a long time
the guy who makes Harvard stuff so keep
that in mind if you still want to
consider by HTC these are the kind of
people they unlock associates with I
know you can't say anything I can say
side I heads anything I guess anything
and he's not gonna sue me so yeah that's
that okay yeah that's a seafood thing
some other stuff like MLM or whatever
yeah I just wanna I just want to say
real quick one funny thing that like is
the line that I'm always balancing on is
like the people don't realize so people
like I think some people look at what I
do and they're like why hasn't anyone
there aren't that many people like
calling these people out and they're
kind of shocked they're like wait this
does seem real sketchy why aren't people
calling off
it's because they all get sued these
people all just sue the people who
criticize them like that's the thing
you've got to be really careful and now
I have I have like insurance literally
just for that I pay like pretty good
money for insurance Wow but anyways I
still you don't want to get it's just
the nightmare if you get sued but like
these people they'll just they'll
they'll sue to shut you up and they'll
sue they'll send you like these cease
and desist letters they'll say hey stop
talking about my name or else and you
could even win the lawsuit but then you
end up losing a bunch of money so just
for people if sometimes I'm kind of a
little careful with my words or whatever
just know that's why it's not because
it's my opinion that these guys are all
right legit in any way but I can't say
anything yeah he's letting me say stuff
because you can't believe me I will cuz
this I hate this dude oh yeah it was
like group leaders they talked about yep
alright so to help to make it look more
like an MLM oh by the way in the inner
circle program he encourages you to do
affiliate marketing I try and sell HTTP
like will be $500 ohm revenues for
everyone signs up with HTC under your
link you get 500 bucks so you know if
you guys want to make some extra money
you can get people to join HTC that is
like a pyramid skin it's like an MLM at
that point yeah but you didn't mention
that like you know I mean I didn't
mention it until you got to the inner
circle then he started talking Billy
links but yeah anyhow was I say oh yeah
I grew up here so in the very beginning
when you first sign up you join a group
it's a group of like I think six or
seven other students and then one group
leader someone who's one of his trusted
in her circle members or someone who
paid you know twenty one hundred dollars
in two hundred bucks a month the joint
is program
and in these groups he's like okay guys
so you actually have a sign hope in
threat the agency program you actually
have assignments that he wants you to
complete and the group leader makes you
like a Google sheets page it's all the
points it's like if you watch the
program live they get four points if you
want to play to get three points there's
like ten points a week you got to go
through and you have to get 50 points
total or else you don't graduate the PhD
right now these computers they basically
have like weekly conference calls with
you and like Oh how's roleplay going
how's this basically you know hey I'm
here to support you please don't please
don't get a refund you know on something
like that it is currently and you know
you just they're basically like the
multi-level marketing thing you know you
have like a group leader trying to like
encourage you to stay in it and whatnot
so that way you know upsell you to the
inner circle program and whatnot and in
fact I Greek leader was a real like he
seemed like a nice dude up internal it
was time to join the inner circle
program and it was really fun
now I was fortunate because I had money
I was making money in my job and
cellebrite remake but this one guy I
feel bad for him I don't want to say his
name
like he worked in a gas station and he
had like a sick mom at home his mom was
like sick and unable to work but he some
house you know scrounge together twenty
five hundred month to join a htc program
and I'm like okay he's trying to make a
better life and then and this this this
really [ __ ] I didn't want to say
anything as you know I gets that ball
you know it's like sketchy but um the
guys like oh yeah the gas station guys
like oh I really want to join the inner
circle program but like like he's like I
spent my life savings of the htc program
and and then the group leader he says
okay um tell him I think PayPal has like
credit loans you can take you know
no ass he had him and in his what's
called and apparently pretty pal didn't
give them enough so it's the UK and I'm
not sure how their banking system works
but I think he's financing immediately
there and he fired canceled two thousand
dollars at like twenty percent interest
or something like that and and and like
you know the group leader was just
encouraging him to do it like [ __ ] man I
was like I was like damn that's really
[ __ ] you got the girl that's not right
man there's like you get there can be
such a thing as like selling with some
ethics if you know someone isn't can't
afford it you don't sell them a two
thousand dollar course while their mom's
sick and then two hundred dollars a
month on top of that and this kick and I
mean you know what I actually tried to
Reese before doing yes actually after
watching that one guys last testimony I
tried reaching out to him and won't
respond to me he won't talk to me like
he doesn't update his status or anything
I'm like damn Mike I hope he's alright
I know like they say [ __ ] this kid's
life up pretty bad you know like that's
why that's why like I really believe in
in getting these like testimonials out
there and just talking about you know
fake gurus is because at the end of the
day where the rubber meets the road is
you have desperate people who don't know
any better who sometimes can't afford it
being up sold endlessly for what exactly
it's also I mean is it just so that Dan
can ride in his Bentley like what is it
for I don't know well again I mean he
has a sexual relationship with money so
maybe that has nothing to do with it I
got over here [ __ ] wrong with this
dude like like what what do you mean you
want to think of money like of love her
that's weird
you're you're weird man ah yeah maybe
that's what it is you just get so greedy
to the point where you just you just
don't care anymore and yeah I mean yeah
and that's I think is that about it I
think that's about it dude this is gonna
be a hell
of a fake career guide you have
something else say oh yeah let's let's
make that the final thing let's see it
so here it is you can see it dust on
right okay so basically yeah Dan pretty
much says okay I want to make you guys
do a test one don't make you but if you
do I really want you guys it makes you
proud
give me a good testimony and okay and
he's like okay guys a really nice
t-shirt like a really really high
quality t-shirt if you do like he's like
anything you know cuz he's talking with
all his friends right that's how it
doesn't right and I got this t-shirt now
when someone went when a
multi-millionaire says I'm gonna give
you guys an extremely high quality
t-shirt uh okay well what do you think
of would you say oh I see I was thinking
like you know okay maybe like Ralph
Lauren or Gucci's I'm sure I mean it's a
high ticket closer you want I mean this
is the closures in black baby
like yeah you know you know we get
guilty in of class of collect guilty in
the stuff you know high schools that
colleges give out as promotional [ __ ]
you know what don't you tell you the
Claudia's program right they're [ __ ]
guilty in with an HTC sticker on that
actual is the HTC program
it's a Gillian shirt oh here it is okay
yeah here is the [ __ ] teacher you can
see it right there see guilty in this is
how you can see HTC right there
oh no but I quality HTC shirt he gives
out that this is [ __ ] brain that's
what you paid $2,500 for and I like
that's about it I mean that's all I can
remember off the top of my head do
appreciate you coming on seriously I
mean it means a lot and I think a lot of
people are gonna find a lot of value in
this man if we can just have one person
kind of get a better perspective on HTC
if it's right for them I think they can
use this interview it's not right for
you it's not
okay no trust me literally it's not
you're not even getting any that really
Tony Robbins book you can buy it you can
literally buy any college textbook it
teaches you the same stuff like two
hundred bucks I Amazon or whatever way
cheaper
[Music]
[Music]
for the car
[Music]